Prof: I'm going to use
today to actually cover some
introductory material.
We will use most of the fifty
minutes.
The last part of today's
lecture will describe the
course, its requirements,
and so forth.
So let's begin.
Capitalism--we're going to
break the subject today into
three headings.
Capital, capitalism,
and course, three
"Cs"
if you will.
The--I've chosen,
and I usually do this,
I've chosen one segment of the
economy as the theme for the
day,
and today that segment is
revealed in this slide.
Calhoun Athletics XXL,
can you interpret the slide?
Student:  Green
technology.
Prof: Okay what in
particular?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay,
how about Varic bottled water?
Student:  Like the crop
circles?
Prof: Okay,
they are indeed crop circles.
Score one for MBAs.
They are crop circles,
and all of us who travel from
east to west across the country
have seen them,
but we haven't seen them quite
in this density because this
photograph is taken from space,
it's a NASA image,
and it's an extraordinarily
elegant display of something
very simple.
Now why would center pivot
agriculture interest us from the
point of view of capitalism?
The mis-formatted slide here
says capital.
This is a definition that comes
down to us through the Oxford
English Dictionary from the
early seventeenth century and
let me read it in full and then
we'll boil it down to more
manageable terms:
"Capital is the
accumulated wealth of an
individual,
company, or community used as a
fund to carry on fresh
production;
wealth in any form used to help
in producing more wealth."
And there's a shift between
those two meanings.
The first is a very broad
understanding of capital.
The second is very close to the
way you would have to think
about capital in connection with
an economic system called
capitalism.
So, let's start with the
broader usage,
"Capital is accumulated
wealth used as a fund in
carrying on fresh
production."
That's a very broad idea.
It is one which arguably--in
fact I think without much
argument,
goes back 10,000 years to the
establishment of agricultural
society,
and very possibly another
100,000 or 120,000 years to
organized hunter gatherers using
weapons and tools.
Does this qualify?
Is that not capital?
What do you think?
Second row purple--
Student:
>
Prof: It is capital.
Sorry, excuse me,
can you hand her this?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay,
so the nuts buried in the
forest floor are accumulated
wealth, so it meets that test.
Does it meet the next test?
You need the mic a little
closer to your mouth.
Student:
>
Prof: Okay so what is
the squirrel producing with that
nut?
Student:  Nothing
material.
Prof: He's producing
squirrel, and that's not really
what we mean.
Hand the mic to somebody else
and we'll just--it's the hot
potato.
Just pass it around and
wherever it is when I ask a
question that's your turn.
That'll be good.
The nest is producing
nestlings, and it's a little
closer to what we mean.
The beaver dam producing a
working environment for beavers
to carry out their business;
it's closer.
Infrastructure if you will.
The honeycomb that bees use.
This one is actually the one
that is closest intuitively to
capital.
Right?
The accumulated wealth is the
energy and silk required to
weave the nest or weave the web,
and the web is indeed an
instrument for the work of
capturing prey,
but there's no external product
beyond it,
so even that is not quite what
we have in mind.
Now how about seed?
The seeds used in agriculture.
Where's the--where's the mic
right now?
Fess up.
Come on in guys.
No, no, no.
You're not passing it off now.
Okay, so do you reckon that
seeds like this constitute
capital?
Student:  Okay,
I don't really think so,
no.
Prof: Okay and why not?
Student:  Well,
I guess that a seed produces a
plant,
but it doesn't really--well I
guess yeah,
maybe the seed produces a
plant, and then the plant
produces more seeds and it sort
of keeps generating more and
more seeds.
Prof: Is that capital?
Student:  I mean it
doesn't look like it to me.
Prof: Why not?
Be exact.
Student:  Well I guess
that capital is sort of a
never-ending way of accumulating
more wealth.
Prof: Does it have to go
on forever?
Don't capitalists fail?
Student:  Yeah
capitalists fail,
but good capitalists don't.
Prof: Take Mory's,
it's a pretty good example.
It's a really good example,
actually.
Okay, mic please.
In this bucket I've got two
kilograms of seed.
Would anybody say that it isn't
enough to count as capital?
If--is one seed,
is that enough to make it
capital?
Student:  What kind of
seeds?.
Prof: It's--
Student:  I said what
kind of seed is it?
Prof: Okay,
it is for growing safflower.
If you elicit information from
me you've got to give me
something back.
Student:  I think seeds
in any quantity can be capital
because each--once you plant it
and if there isn't successful
pollination--
Prof: Is the voice loud
enough here?
Student:
You can always use plants to
produce more seed.
In fact, that's what a lot of
farms do and that's what a lot
of farms get in trouble for
because other companies want to
control those seeds.
Prof: Okay,
so there's a patent violation
issue if I use hybrid seed to
generate more hybrid seed?
There may be,
there's an argument there.
Okay, so quantity doesn't
matter at all?
Yes.
Student:  I'd say
quantity matters if you're a
subsistence farmer because if
you just have enough seed to
feed yourself,
that's not capital that's just
keeping you alive,
you're not producing any
further wealth from it.
Prof: Okay and if I gave
you just this much seed?
Student:  Well if I'm
not a farmer,
if I have some other means of
supporting myself that could be
capital for a side business but
that wouldn't be for a
subsistence farmer.
Prof: You think it's
really worth having a business
over twenty-six safflower seeds?
Student:  Well no.
Prof: No,
I don't think so either.
What I'm driving at here is the
notion of minimum efficient
scale.
Capital gets--a resource gets
to be capital only when it's
aggregated to a scale where it
can be effectively enough
deployed to compete in an actual
economy.
Now let's take--that's too big
a note, let's take a dollar.
Have I just given you capital
or not?
Student:  Technically
yes, but probably that wouldn't
allow me to set up a budding
business over here.
Prof: Okay,
how might it become a piece of
capital?
Student:  Well if
somebody else gives me a dollar
or more.
Prof: Two dollars is
enough for you to call it
capital?
Student:  No,
but if I have more investors
and they will be giving more
than a dollar.
Prof: Okay,
so you need some aggregation or
agglomeration.
How do we aggregate capital in
an actual economy?
Student:  IPOs.
Prof: IPOs are a big way
to do it.
In general, the joint stock
corporation is a way to do it.
How do banks aggregate capital?
Student:  Deposits.
Prof: Thousands of
little deposits make big funds.
Okay, so we're getting there
with capital and what I want to
do now is continue the
agricultural theme and see if we
can relate what we're talking
about to the generation of
actual wealth in society.
This is called a seed drill.
It is a way of planting
millions of seeds in a very
systematic, precise,
and cost effective way.
One characteristic feature of
how capital works is combining
different factors in the
production of the same thing in
an extremely intelligent way.
A way that represents the
accumulated experience of
society and when you do it well
you succeed, and when you do it
poorly you fail.
You can actually fail even when
you do it well,
but you're very unlikely to
succeed when you do it poorly.
Now here I want to compare two
very similar technologies,
this is a peasant farming in
Tibet and the mode of power here
is a pair of yaks,
and this is a John Deere
tractor and the spectacular
difference between these two
things is obvious to us all.
It is that one of them
is--constitutes a large
investment of capital.
In the case of that tractor and
the gear with it well over
$100,000 must be invested.
The yaks, well I don't know
what yaks cost in Tibet,
but less.
We would say that the John
Deere photograph represents
something that's capital
intensive and the yak photograph
represents something which is
labor intensive.
We would expect a much higher
return in food generated per
hour of labor invested from the
highly mechanized capital
intensive story.
In the history of the world in
the last thousand years is
essentially the history of
substitution of the right hand
picture for the left hand;
of capital intensive,
highly mechanized means of
production in the place of labor
intensive, low capitalization
means of production.
Another comparison,
the capital intensivity here,
the ratio of that watering cans
capital cost to the center pivot
that might be as much as 500
meters long would be measured in
the thousands to one,
the tens of thousands,
the hundreds of thousands
probably;
enormous difference in the
level of investment.
Also those of you who are
interested in the environment,
and all of us should be,
there is a huge difference in
environmental impact.
The labor intensive agriculture
essentially leaves the
environment unchanged,
whereas, this kind of
agriculture practiced in--
it's now a world--center pivot
irrigation is a worldwide
technology.
And in many places it draws so
much water so fast,
and so much water is lost to
evaporation, that the underlying
aquifer is rapidly being
depleted.
Here are two center pivot
photographs, and they too differ
in capitalization.
The one on the left is from
Egypt, the one on the right is
from Iowa, and the difference
between them in the cost of the
land would be dramatic.
The market price of highly
productive loam soil in one of
the three or four richest
agricultural zones in the world
is much higher than in the
margin of the world's largest
desert.
Here's another--I kind of got
carried away with center pivot
agriculture.
Here's another slide of the
same kind from the same source,
and this is in Southern France.
Who's been to Southern France?
Pretty great isn't it?
I have many reservations about
French politics but Southern
France is one of the nicest
places I've ever been,
and this summer--we'll meet a
guy here in a month named Paolo
Zannoni,
who is a robber baron Goldman
Sachs partner,
and he just built a villa
overlooking Cannes in Southern
France,
and I had to be taken away by
security.
What's striking about this
photograph in comparison with
the others--
what's the dramatic difference
between this one and the
Egyptian one,
and the Iowa one?
Purple?
That's not what I'm fishing for
guys.
Student:  There's other
things in the middle.
Prof: Okay you got to
talk really--where's--do I have
the mic?
Here it is.
Would you please pass this over
to him?
Student:  There's other
things in the middle of the
green and purple circles.
Prof: Push the on button
and it'll be on.
Student: Alright,
there's other things in the
middle of the green and purple
circles.
Prof: Okay,
and what are the other things?
Student:  I can't tell
if they're houses or--
Prof: Well what are all
these little polygons?
Look at the right margin,
for example.
They are--take a guess,
they're not soccer fields.
Who wants to take a guess at
this?
Yes.
Student:  Pasture.
Prof: Pasture?
Okay they might be pasture.
What they are more
generally--you have the--we'll
get better at this microphone
thing as we go.
What they are is very small
farms.
They're farms where the leaps
and bounds trace back perhaps
800,1,000,1,200 years.
They were farms which worked
economically when the world was
less developed in capital
intensive agriculture,
but they have been rendered
marginal by the transformation
of world agriculture.
Now the question for you--are
you ready for a policy question?
Okay, your name is now Sarkozy,
and the question is,
should we increase--let's
suppose that 20% of these farms
are failing a year,
and we're already subsidizing
them pretty heavily.
Should we subsidize them more
so that the rate at which they
close down is diminished?
Mr.***Sarkozy?
Student:  I would say if
you really want to effectively
decrease the rate at which
they're failing you'd want to
encourage consolidation.
It looks like the problem here
is real fragmentation.
Prof: Okay,
the problem is fragmentation,
that's a really good start.
Now the person immediately to
your right is your political
consultant,
and she's going to tell you
whether what you just said is
going to wash in Lyon or not.
How's the Sarkozy consolidation
program, how's that going to
play?
Student:  Can you repeat
the question?
Prof: Okay,
Sarkozy just said these little
fragments of land are an
extremely inefficient way to do
agriculture.
He/she was right on that point.
She goes on to say that we
should try to capture the scale
economies of big fields by
consolidating agriculture.
Now you are a public official
subject to election.
What--how is that going to read
for you, that statement that we
should announce the Sarkozy
Agricultural Consolidation Plan?
Student:  I don't think
that the public would like it,
like the small farmers.
Prof: The small farmers
would hate it,
and do the small farmers play a
special role in the life and
imagination of France?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Yes.
Okay so probably it won't
happen and France--
this is a characteristic fact
about all the capitalist
democracies is that pressure
groups play an enormously
important role in actual policy.
The one book,
which is available for purchase
at Labyrinth,
but which isn't actually
required, is Christopher
Buckley's Thank You For
Smoking.
How many of you have read this
book?
Student:  Probably
watched the movie.
Prof: Pardon?
Student:  The movie.
Prof: Oh, the movie!
How many of you have seen the
movie?
Books!
It's all about the biases of
pressure groups and public
relations in the capitalist--in
the largest capitalist
democracy, which is our own.
I just couldn't resist throwing
this one in,
this is the Libyan Desert and
center pivot agriculture plus
maybe something else that
uncles--
observers from the sky found
interesting.
Okay so a general theme here,
Strategy A / Strategy B.
Strategy A is labor intensive
production.
Strategy B is capital intensive
The single biggest story,
and I'm repeating myself here
because it's such a big point,
in recent world history is the
substitution of Strategy B for
Strategy A,
and that happening on an
extremely uneven basis.
It's happening in a big way and
fast some places,
and in a little way and slow
other places,
and that generates an enormous
vertical dimension to the world.
There are income ratios between
households measured in the
millions,
millions to one,
and that provides some of the
interest in the functioning of
capitalism which brings us to
the subject.
Now comparing labor intensive,
the red arrow,
with capital intensive,
the blue arrow,
we have here a very simple
production function where labor
expended is on the horizontal
axis,
and units produced is on the
vertical.
For those of who are actually
taking this course,
these slides I posted them just
before class and so if you--
you can just--you don't have to
write this stuff down.
If you project differences in
rates of return over long
periods,
here I've put 100 production
cycles,
and one curve is increasing at
1%, the red one,
the other is increasing at 4%
per cycle,
and by the end of the period
there is a monstrous difference
in the rate at which they are
accumulating.
In actual fact very small
differences, I've greatly
overstated them in the
production function here.
The difference between 4% and
3%, or between 2.5% and 1%,
are enormously consequential
when projected over time.
And at a given moment in time,
are enormously consequential
from a competitive point of
view,
because if you are not the low
cost producer,
the low cost producer is in a
position where if she has
sufficient scale of operation,
she can drive you out of
business.
Now everything we've said so
far could be true of almost any
economic system.
I put the grass here to suggest
Tang, China.
This was one of the great
periods in Chinese cultural and
economic history,
ending more than a thousand
years ago.
The use of capital,
not necessarily in the highly
intensive form,
but the use of capital in this
economic cycle we're talking
about was a perfectly normal
practice which the Tang Dynasty
would have understood easily.
They were, by the way,
just as inventive as we have
been in the last couple of
hundred years.
What they didn't have was the
ability to go to scale.
Or it could have been as
suggested in this Bruegel
painting,
we could be thinking of Europe
in the fifteenth century or the
sixteenth century before the
capitalist revolution because
there was always the reliance on
capital.
Lower levels of intensivity
because there was less capital
in total.
And it could even have been,
we could even be talking about
an agricultural cooperative in
the Soviet Union,
which used capital in the form
of tractors and land,
and seed, and so on,
but used it in a very different
way than it is used in market
economies.
Two: capitalism.
Let's switch now to the lower
usage here.
It is the use of accumulated
wealth to produce more wealth.
Marx makes a big point of this
wealth, commodity,
wealth--WCW--and sees this as
pathological,
as a distortion of human
values.
And we'll talk through Marx in
about a week or ten days.
The great man--how many of you
have read as many as ten pages
of Marx's writing?
Where do we read Marx at Yale
these days?
Student:  Philosophy.
Prof: Philosophy
department.
Where else?
Student:  Sociology.
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  Directed studies.
What is directed studies read
of Marx?
Student:
>
Prof: "Communist
Manifesto";
that's great,
you're well prepared for this
class because we're going to
read it next week.
What would you say of Marx as a
writer?
First of all he wrote in
German, but who's got an
editorial opinion about Marx's
writing?
Yes.
Student:  I think--
Prof: You've got to
shout without the mic.
Student:  A very
talented writer.
Prof: A very talented
writer.
I agree;
a very smart guy.
If you were marking a Marx term
paper up, what would you find
fault with?
Student:  A bit
long-winded.
Prof: Very windy and a
little overwrought,
right?
He really wants to hit you in
the face five times with each
thought.
But what we'll discover is
interesting is that Marx,
in the Manifesto,
Marx and Engels,
look at capitalism in a way
very similar to the way we look
at it today.
They emphasize its enormous
productive capacity and they
also emphasize that it is always
on the edge of being out of
control.
Capitalism, as a word,
comes into the English language
in the middle of the 1800s,
and it comes in because of Marx
and people like Marx.
It is a pejorative used to
attack the existing economic
system.
Capitalism is seen not as a
highly productive system but as
an unjust system,
and it's criticized in other
ways which I'll tick off in a
moment.
Anybody recognize this fellow?
Yes.
Student:  J.P.***Morgan.
Prof: It's J.P.
Morgan and does anybody know
who took this photograph?
That's a little hard;
Steichen.
And it's a very famous
photograph.
What's famous about it?
What does--what's striking
about this image?
Student:  His face.
Prof: Does he look
friendly, warm and fuzzy?
No, and he wasn't.
I mean this was a very hard
edge guy.
What seems to be in his left
hand?
Student:  A chair.
Prof: It is a chair--it
is the arm of a chair,
but the reflection makes it
look like he's holding a dagger.
It was no accident.
Steichen was not a fan and this
has been used--this photograph's
been used thousands of times in
a polemical way.
Okay, capitalism as seen in the
nineteenth century.
A disease for which scientific
socialism, that's Marx's term
for Marx, is the cure.
Of course there were twenty or
thirty other brands of socialism
that Marx regarded as
unscientific.
It is a method by which to
steal the labor from the
exploited masses.
The reasoning,
which we'll review in ten days
time,
is that capital can never make
money except by using either
labor now or the accumulated
fruit of labor from the past,
and if capital ends up with a
profit,
that profit must be extracted
from either living or fossilized
labor.
This is not a thought which I
share.
It is a system which undermines
traditional society in all its
forms, and undermines
traditional skill sets,
and that's a perfectly true
statement.
When it happens it is very
coercive.
It is indeed a trademark of the
way capitalism works.
That a skill set which was
competitive and au
courant in 1980 may not
command as much as the minimum
wage in 2009.
This is the kicker for Marx;
it is the claim that capitalism
inevitably will destroy itself.
It will undermine its own
foundations and ultimately
disappear.
We'll evaluate that view.
This slide has cut off the main
part of the--of what's here so
I'll have to remember it for
you.
Capitalism is the name given to
an economic system by its
enemies;
point one by its enemies.
Point two a system which relies
heavily on the private use of
capital;
capital combined with the profit
motive founded on self interest
or family interest.
There are hundreds of
variations on the capitalist
system,
but the essentials are private
deployment of capital,
open acknowledgement of profit
as a motive,
and a sympathetic understanding
of self or household interest.
Another frequent part of the
package is a tolerance for
innovation.
One of the characteristic facts
about historical society is a
resistance to innovation.
And the temptation to resist
change is always there.
It is absolutely always there
and as people grow older they
grow more set in their ways and
expectations and less tolerant
of fresh innovation.
This course.
We're going to start with some
excerpts from the Wealth Of
Nations.
It is available on Class V2
posted under resources.
How many of you have read at
least a chapter of Wealth of
Nations?
Okay, the rest of you are in
for a treat.
Smith is not only a great
writer but a great thinker.
He is a much more complex
thinker than we usually imagine
him to be.
He was not a believer that it's
just fine for the poor to starve
in the streets.
He actually had very
complicated news about that
which are broadly analogous to
the philosopher John Rawls,
and Rawls' difference principle
about what inequalities are
justified,
namely those which
>
ultimately in some way to the
benefit of the least favored
stratum in an economy.
The Manifesto,
already mentioned,
and in both cases we'll leave
out a good bit.
Smith is a very old book.
I recommend to you the Bantam
paperback,
$7.95 of Smith because it has
wonderful little summaries of
each paragraph in italics which
allow speed reading,
which is actually a very useful
thing when a book would take a
week to plow through in a
careful reading.
We'll focus on just three or
four points there,
three or four arguments in
Smith, but they are really
powerful and important readings.
The Constitution of
Liberty is by F.A.
Hayek and we'll just read two
chapters that will be in a
packet, which you will get.
Hayek is the arch-conservative,
a market conservative from whom
most of the conservative
movement--
not not concerned with social
authority--
but the libertarian side of
American conservatism relies
primarily on Hayek,
actually.
Farewell to Alms,
this book, by a guy named
Gregory Clarke,
is a book which says
capitalism: more and better;
pour it on.
As capitalism increases its
reach the world will grow
wealthier and better.
It is a polemical work,
written by an economist,
and you will find things to
argue with even if you more or
less agree with him you will
find many things to argue with
him about and that will be an
important book in the course.
The Mystery of Capital
by Hernando DeSoto is an
argument about why the less
developed countries in the world
are less developed,
and the gist of it is that
formal and enforceable property
rights are a precondition to
capital development.
It's a very powerful piece of
work.
Richard Posner,
The Failure of
Capitalism,
Posner--anybody know who Posner
is?
Tell us loud and clear.
Student:  A judge.
Prof: He's a judge and
he's a judge of what persuasion,
would you say?
He's a very conservative judge,
teaches at The University of
Chicago Law School,
and he has written a very
penetrating analysis of the
current crisis.
It is--I read maybe 20 books
and picked one on this subject,
and this is the clearest and
most honest,
I think, and he doesn't--he
does no ideological distortion
here that I can detect.
It is just a penetrating and
straightforward analysis of what
happened, and for that reason
very useful.
The Bottom Billion by
Paul Collier,
who is a World Bank economist
who teaches at Oxford,
and in this maps out a
diagnosis and a strategy for
using market mechanisms and
capital development to alleviate
most of the world's poverty.
Finally, The White
Tiger, this is fiction,
but there are times when
fiction is better at describing
the real world than nonfiction.
This is a brutally penetrating
novel written from the point of
view of a very poor,
very smart, and in many ways
flawed young man in South India.
It won the Man Booker prize
last year for fiction.
It is, for our age,
it is as good as Dickens and
Zola were for the nineteenth
century.
It's just a brilliant book.
I couldn't put it down.
Ten people told me I had to
read it, and I kept shrugging my
shoulders and that's when I
started, and I read it front to
back in one long day.
It is--if you want to
understand why there are a
billion or two billion people
out there for whom capitalism
looks not like a powerful
mechanism of production but like
an extremely coercive system.
The White Tiger is a
great way to do that.
Chris Buckley's,
Thank You For Smoking,
is optional.
We will also use the case
method and the case method
occupies about a third of the
course.
We will use--the ones in white
are straightforward cases,
the ones in gold we'll have the
people in the room or some of
the people.
Polaroid is the story of the
land camera and a brilliant
technology which ultimately
crashed and burned,
and it's--the case is a hard
business school case about the
attempt to get that business
through its crisis at the time
that it went broke.
Goldman Sachs IPO
terrifically--it's a good HBS
case,
and better yet we'll have Paolo
Zannoni with us to tell the
story from the inside of the
Goldman system.
Wanda Rapaczynski is the story
of getting a business going in
Poland just after the death of
communism.
A Yale-trained business woman
who created something called
Agora S.A.,
which is the largest publishing
company in East Europe,
and how she coped with the
toxic environment,
the toxic business environment,
left over by communism.
Selco India is a microfinance
story.
Cardiothoracic Systems is a
tech story and I'm going to have
the Dean of SOM come and do it
as a business case with you,
which means you're going to
need to wear helmets.
She is an aggressive cold
caller.
By the way, I'm going to make
two kinds of calls in this
course,
cold calls are the kind of
thing I did today where you get
no warning,
and warm calls I'll send you an
email and say heads up about,
and in the second case you've
really got to have something to
say.
Some of the fun in this stuff
is the back and forth between
you and me, and you and you.
The Enron case,
Jim Alexander is an important
guy in this course.
Jim would you just stand up and
wave?
Jim was--Jim is a good friend
of mine who had a career in
investment banking and then at
Enron,
and he was Chief Financial
Officer of Enron,
Global Pipeline & Power,
and he saw what was happening
and got out.
He is referred to as the fly in
the ointment in Smartest Guys
in the Room,
which is the popularized story
of Enron's crash.
He then went on and co-founded
Spinnaker Exploration whose
operating principle was:
think what Enron would do and
do the opposite.
Spinnaker became a public
company and was extremely
successful.
Medley Global Advisors,
this is a case about gathering
business intelligence and
selling it at high prices.
Medley is another Yale-trained
person.
He founded the company and the
case is about his attempt to
sell the company,
which he did,
so he's selling a company
that--
which is posthumously his,
and he actually sold it for
fifty seven million bucks,
and it's a no venture medley
story and he's a very
interesting guy.
Then maybe we'll talk about
Mory's.
I'm chair of a workout
committee which is trying to put
more effective business and it
turns out to be a really
interesting hard case.